हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू
ऑल तो सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है ओके थैंक यू शुभम बाकी सभी
को दे आर ओनली एट स्टूडेंट्स थोड़ा सा वेट
करते हैं हम ओनली 10 तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते
हैं हम नेक्स्ट टू से ी मिनट का
स्टूडेंट्स को जवाइन होने देते हैं मुझे
पता है कि 20 से ऊपर कोई स्टूडेंट्स आएगा
नहीं क्यों किसी को इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में दे आर नॉट मतलब की
पैशनेट अबाउट द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एंड हेलो अभी सेक एंड
देखिए अभी बिल्कुल फ्रेशर हो तो अभी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है बट एक बार आपको सार
चीजों के बारे में पता चल जाएगा जैसे कि
पन टेस्टिंग होती कैसे है टूल्स कैसे यूज
होते हैं और फंडामेंटल्स आपके क् क्लियर
हो जाएंगे और आपके पास एक अप्रोच होगी तो
उसके बाद फिर आपको स्क्रिप्टिंग की जरूरत
पड़ती है अपने काम को ऑटोमेशन में डालने
के लिए तो सबसे पहले आप अपना फंडामेंटल्स
बेसिक और अपनी अप्रोच बनाइए देन उसके बाद
गो फॉर पाइथन एक प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
डेफिनेटली जाइए स इसमें आपको
एक्सप्लोइटेशन भी आना चाहिए और आपको
बेसिकली थोड़ा एक्सप्लोइट लिखने आने चाहिए
अगर आपको और ज्यादा प्रोफेशनल बनना है
तो ओके हां दो मिनट हम वेट करेंगे
अभिषेक वेरी गुड इवनिंग मान सिंह शर्मा तो
आज का हमारा टॉपिक काफी इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा
तो तो सबसे पहले तब तक बाकी
स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आते तब तक के लिए आप
मुझसे कोई भी सवाल पूछ सकते हो रिलेटेड टू
द बैक अभी तक डेट 34 तक जितने भी हमने
क्लासेस लिए हैं तो आप उससे रिलेटेड मुझसे
क्वेश्चन पूछ सकते हो उन क्लास अगर आपको
कोई भी डाउट है
तो तो पाइथन हार्ड नहीं है यार पाइथन को
सीखना हार्ड नहीं और अभी पाइथन आपने बेसिक
सीख लिया उसके बाद आपको स्क्रिप्ट बनानी
है तो चट जीपीटी वेरी यूजफुल फॉर यू उसको
अगर आपने यूज करना आता है उसकी प्रोमट
इंजीनियरिंग के तो काफी अच्छा
रहेगा यूडी टेक फिर आप तो नितेश सर से
पूछिए वो चीज कब आएंगे लाइव क्योंकि अभी
एक बार में दो कोर्सेस नहीं पढ़ाए जाते
क्योंकि एक साथ हम दो कोर्सेस पढ़ाएंगे ना
उसमें हमारी कोर्स की वैल्यू नहीं है सच
बात यही है क्योंकि आपको इंटरेस्ट है उनके
कोर्स में और इधर भी आपको एक दोनों जगह
आपका इंटरेस्ट है बट एट ए टाइम आप एक ही
चीज को देख सकते हो ना तो दैट इज वई
आपके आएंगे मेरा नाम पूछ रहे हो तो बताना
बाकी स्टूडेंट्स बता देंगे मेरा नाम आप
इतनी बार क्वेश्चन में क्लासेस में सवाल
पूछते हो यूडी टेक कई बार मैंने आपको देखा
है और आप मेरा नाम पूछे हो एंड थैंक यू
अगर आपको नाम नहीं
पता दे ओनली 14 स्टूडेंट अभी भी
देखिए यह हालात है हमारी लाइव क्लासेस का
तो यूडी टेक बग बाउंट के अलावा आपने कुछ
किया नहीं है तो आप अभी प्रेजेंटली काम कर
रहे हो कहीं पर बग बाउंट तो मुझे लगता आप
अच्छे से कर रहे होंगे बाकी तो आपको जॉब
आसानी से मिल गई होगी ओनली फॉर बग बाउंट
के बेस पर
आपको नहीं मुझे अभी ऐसा कोई आईडिया नहीं
है बब सूट के जैसा कौन सा नया टूल है बब
सूट के अलावा तो बब सूट जैसा तो एक ही टूल
है जो फ्री है ओपन सोर्स है जिसको हम
बोलते हैं जप
प्रॉक्सी और अगर ऐसा कुछ आया है तो आई विल
फाइंड
आउट ओके क्लास को स्टार्ट करें फिर
इससे ऊपर स्टूडेंट नहीं आएंगे मुझे पता
है चलिए क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं
फिर जो आज का हमारा टॉपिक है वह है विंडोज
सर्विसेस के बारे
में तो विंडोज सर्विसेस होते क्या
है विंडोज सर्विस को कौन कंट्रोल करता है
और कौन इंस्टॉल करता कर सकता है ओके यह जो
तीनों सवाल है इनका आंसर मैं करने की
कोशिश करूंगा कि विंडो सर्विसेस होती क्या
है कौन उनको कंट्रोल करता है और कौन उनको
इंस्टॉल कर सकता है कौन उसको मैनेज करता
है जज आर द थ्री क्वेश्चन ओके तो अभी हम
बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट कि सर्विसेस आर एन
इंपोर्टेंट पार्ट ऑफ विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम अब ओनली नॉट फॉर ओनली विंडोज चाहे
वो नक् हो या कोई भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो
सर्विस एक मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट पार्ट होता है
किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स के लिए और ये
कॉमन अटैक वेक्टर्स भी है खास कर के
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन और पर्सिस के लिए
किसी भी अटैकर्स या पेंटेस्टर्स के लिए एक
कॉमन अटैक वेक्टर होता है आपका
सर्विसेस जिसकी हेल्प से वो आपका
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन और पर्सिस जैसे अटैक
परफॉर्म करता है देयर आर सम सर्विसेस
स्पेशली कस्टम सर्विसेस रन विद हाई
प्रिविलेज लेवल्स एंड आर सेट टू रीस्टार्ट
देम सेल्व ऑन द बोट
अभी बहुत सारी कुछ सर्विसेस ऐसी होती है
खास कर के जो कस्टम सर्विसेस हैं जिनके
पास हाई प्रिविलेज होते हैं हाई लेवल के
प्रिजेस होते हैं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर लेवल के
प्रिजेस होते हैं
एंड उनको सेट किया जाता है कि जैसे आपका
सिस्टम बूट करेगा या आपका सिस्टम रि
स्टार्ट करेगा उन्हीं के साथ वह सर्विसेस
आपकी रन
करेंगी अभी सर्विसेस भी एक प्रोसेस है
सर्विसेस आर आल्सो ए प्रोसेस सबको पता है
कि मैंने आपको बताया था कि ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम में हर एक चीज प्रोसेस के रूप में
काम करती है चाहे वो सर्विसेस हो चाहे
एप्लीकेशन हो सारी सारी क्या है प्रोसेसेस
है प्रोसेस एक कंटेनर है दे आर आल दे आर
आल्सो वेरी क्रिटिकल टू फंक्शनिंग ऑफ द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अब जो सर्विसेस है आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को फंक्शन करने के लिए
दिस इज वेरी वेरी क्रिटिकल कैसे मैं आपको
बताता
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल द ओनली रीजन यू कैन
फाइंड एनीथिंग ऑन द इंटरनेट बिकॉज यू हैव
ए डीएनएस सर्विस रनिंग ऑन टू योर मशीन दैट
अलाउ यू टू गो आउट ए क्यूरी टू डीएनएस अभी
आप इंटरनेट पर कुछ भी फाइंड आउट तभी कर
पाते हो जब उसके लिए एक सर्विस रन करती है
जिसका नाम है डीएनएस अगर आपके सिस्टम्स
में डीएनएस सर्विस रन नहीं करेगी तो आप
इंटरनेट प कुछ भी फाइंड आउट नहीं कर पाओगे
ओके तो दैट इज वन एग्जांपल सेकंड एग्जांपल
यू ओनली गेट द आईपी एड्रेस फ्रॉम डीएचसीपी
सर्वर इफ डीएचसीपी सर्वर सर्विस इज रनिंग
अभी आपको इंटरनेट पर या आपके एक लोकल
एरिया नेटवर्क में या किसी भी नेटवर्क के
अंदर आपको आईपी तभी मिल पाता है जब आपका
डीएचसीपी सर्वर सर्विस रन कर रही है या जो
आपके डीएचसीपी सर्वर है और उसकी सर्विस रन
कर रही है अगर आपके राउटर्स पर या जहां से
अभी आपको इंटरनेट मिल रहा है अगर उसके ऊपर
डीएचसीपी सर्विस रन नहीं कर रही तो आपको
वहां पर आईपी एड्रेस नहीं मिलेगा वहां पर
आपको या तो स्टैटिकली आईपी एड्रेस डालना
पड़ेगा या फिर आपको आईपी एड्रेस नहीं
मिलेगा तो आपकी मशीन कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर
पाएगी अदर डिवाइस से इफ यू डिड नॉट हैव
दोस सर्विसेस रनिंग ऑन योर पीसी देन यू
डिड नॉट गेट दिस फैसिलिटी अगर यह सर्विसेस
जैसे कि मैंने आपको डीएसीपी स सर्विस की
बात की चाहे डीएनएस की बात की या बहुत
सारी अदर सर्विसेस हैं अगर यह सर्विसेस
आपके पीसी पर आपकी मशीन पर रन नहीं करेंगी
तो आपको जो सुविधाएं मिल रही हैं वो
सुविधाएं नहीं मिलेंगी आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के ऊपर क्योंकि इतना स्मूथली रन कर
रहा है आपका सिस्टम आपको फील भी नहीं होता
बिकॉज ऑफ दज सर्विसेस अभी इन सर्विसेस को
समझते हैं कि फॉर एग्जांपल अभी विंडो
सर्विसेस आर लाइक ए बैकग्राउंड स्टाफ इन
होटल एक एग्जांपल की समझते स हेल्प से
समझने की कोशिश करते हैं कि सर्विसेस होती
क्या है कि आप विंडोज सर्विसेस को सोचिए
कि जो होटल्स का जो स्टाफ होता है
बैकग्राउंड में उसकी तरह सोच कि यह
सर्विसेस है फॉर एग्जांपल इमेजिन यू आर
स्टेइंग इन लगजरी
होटल आप किसी भी एक लग्जरी होटल के अंदर
आते हैं रहने के लिए एंड वहां पर आपने
क्या किया आपने एक रूम बुक किया एंड यू
रिलैक्स इन योर रूम एंड एट द सेम टाइम
मेनी थिंग्स हैपेंस बिहाइंड द सीन टू
इंश्योर ए स्मूथ यूजर एक्सपीरियंस अभी जब
आप अपने रूम में रिलैक्स कर रहे होते हो
आराम कर रहे होते हो चाहे आप मूवी देखो
व्हाट एवर यू आर डूइंग तो उस टाइम पर बहुत
सारी चीजें एक साथ हो रही होती हैं आपके
बिहाइंड में जो आपको पता भी नहीं चलता
आपके यूजर एक्सपीरियंस को स्मूथ बनाने के
लिए आपके होटल स्टाफ के द्वारा इवन आपका
उन सर्विसेस डायरेक्टली कोई कंसर्न रहता
भी नहीं और आपको पता भी नहीं चलता लेकिन
आपके यूजर एक्सपीरियंस को या आपकी
सर्विसेस को प्रोवाइड करने के लिए वो बहुत
ही एफिशिएंटली से काम करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल वो कौन सी सर्विसेस की बात कर
रहा हूं मैं होटल की सर्विसेस को विंडोज
के सर्विसेस के साथ कंपेयर करने की कोशिश
करता हूं ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए फॉर
एग्जांपल हाउसकीपिंग कीप्स रूम क्लीन
ऑटोमेटिक एवरी डे सबको पता है कि जो
हाउसकीपिंग हैं वो हमेशा ऑटोमेटिक बिना
कुछ कहे आपके रूम्स को क्लीन करते हैं सेम
लाइक इन विंडोज विंडोज अपडेट सर्विस
ऑटोमेटिक अपडेट योर सिस्टम आपको कभी भी
विज को बोलना नहीं पड़ता कि आपके सिस्टम
को अपडेट कीजिए आपका विंडोज ऑटोमेटिक आपके
सिस्टम्स को अपडेट करके रखता है इसका मतलब
सम सर्विसेस वर्क्स कंटीन्यूअसली दैट इज
कॉल्ड ऑटोमेटिक सर्विस इसका मतलब यह है कि
कुछ सर्विसेस ऑटोमेटिक काम कर रही होती है
आपके विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर या
किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर तो उन
सर्विस को हम बोलते हैं दीज आर ऑटोमेटिक
सर्विस जस्ट लाइक हाफ कीपिंग स्टप क्लीन
रूम्स एवरी डे विदाउट यू आस्किंग सम
विंडोज सर्विसेस स्टार्ट ऑटोमेटिक व्हेन
कंप्यूटर बूट्स एंड कीप रनिंग जैसे ही जो
आपका हाउसकीपिंग स्टाफ है हर रोज उस कमरों
की सफाई करते हैं बिना किसी से पूछे आपसे
पूछे खास कर के जो यूजर्स हैं जो उनको यूज
करते हैं उनसे बिना पूछे उसी प्रकार से
विंडोज में भी बहुत सारी सर्विसेस जैसे
आपका कंप्यूटर बूट करता है आपका रन करता
है वो सर्विस स्टार्ट हो जाती है बिना
किसी यूजर से इंटरेक्ट किए और पूछे हुए
ओके फॉर एग्जांपल विंडोस डिफेंडर जो
एंटीवायरस होता है वह हमेशा रन करता रहता
है आपके सिस्टम को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए
दैट इज वन एग्जांपल सेकंड एग्जांपल्स रूम
सर्विस डिलीवर्स फूड ओनली व्हेन ए गेस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट इट अभी कभी भी आपने अगर होटल
में स्टे किया होगा किसी रूम में स्टे
किया होगा तो वहां पर आप क्या करते हो एक
टेलीफोन से कॉल करते हो कि मुझे 100 100
फूड आइटम्स चाहिए तो आपको वो रूम सर्विस
में वो सारे सारे फूड प्रोवाइड किए जाते
है जो आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट होती है तो वो
आपकी कॉल पर ही काम करता है उसी प्रकार से
जैसे प्रिंस पुलर सर्विस होती है रंस ओनली
व्हेन ए यूजर प्रिंट्स ए डॉक्यूमेंट जब आप
प्रिंट कमांड एंटर करते हो आप प्रिंट दे
हो तभी प्रिंट्स पुलर सर्विस रन करती है
और आपके डॉक्यूमेंट को प्रिंट करती है
इसका मतलब सम सर्विसेस स्टार्ट ओनली वन
नीडेड दैट इज मैनुअल सर्विस इसका मतलब यह
है कि कुछ सर्विसेस ऐसी हैं जो ओनली तभी
स्टार्ट होंगी जब जरूरत होगी जब उनको
ट्रिगर किया जाएगा जब उनको कॉल किया जाएगा
तो उनको हम बोल सकते हैं मैनुअल सर्विस
जस्ट लाइक रूम सर्विस प्रिपेयर फूड्स ओनली
व्हेन ए गेस रिक्वेस्ट इड सम विंडो ो
सर्विसेस स्टार्ट ओनली व्हेन रिक्वायर्ड
समझ में आया फॉर एग्जांपल ब्लूटूथ सर्विस
स्टार्ट ओनली व्हेन यू ट्राई टू कनेक्ट टू
ए ब्लूटूथ डिवाइस जैसे ही आप जब तक फूड का
ऑर्डर नहीं दोगे तब तक आपका फूड तैयार
नहीं होगा उसी प्रकार से जब तक आप किसी
विंडोज की मैनुअल सर्विस को कॉल नहीं करो
तब तक उस सर्विस को रन नहीं किया जाएगा
ओके ब्लूटूथ का एक वेरी गुड एग्जांपल आपको
अगर ब्लूटूथ डिवाइस कनेक्ट करना है तो
आपको क्या करना पड़ता है अपने पीसी में
लैपटॉप में या आपके सिस्टम्स के ऊपर
ब्लूटूथ के सर्विस को ऑन करना पड़ता है
देन ओनली आप उस ब्लूटूथ डिवाइस से कनेक्ट
होते हैं दैट इज सेकंड एग्जांपल्स नाउ
थर्ड एग्जांपल की बात करते हैं
हम सिक्योरिटी गार्ड्स मॉनिटर द होटल 24 *
7 टू कीप इट सेफ जो सिक्योरिटी गार्ड्स
होते हैं वो लगातार 24 * 7 क्या करते हैं
आपके होटल्स को मॉनिटरिंग करते रहते हैं
ताकि आपका होटल सेफ रहे उसी प्रकार से अगर
विंडोज की बात करें द एंटी वायर सर्विस
रंस इन द बैकग्राउंड टू प्रोटेक्ट योर
पीसी डेफिनेटली जैसे सिक्योरिटी गार्ड काम
करते हैं किसी भी होटल्स के लिए उसी
प्रकार से आपके विंडोज के लिए एंटी वायर
सर्विसेस काम करती है बैकग्राउंड में जो
आपको पता भी नहीं रहता तो दे वर्क इन द
बैकग्राउंड विदाउट
डिस्टर्बिया जाता ओके तो दैट इज द थर्ड
एग्जांपल नाउ कम्स टू द फोर्थ एग्जांपल्स
र भी बहुत सारे एग्जांपल्स है मैं कंपेज
सिमिलरली द फ्रंट डेस्क इज ऑलवेज अवेलेबल
टू हैंडल गैस रिक्वेस्ट अभी जो रिसेप्शंस
होता है रिसेप्शंस क्यों होता है किसी भी
होटल्स में आपकी गैस रिक्वेस्ट को हैंडल
करने के के लिए ओके उसी प्रकार से आपके
विंडोज में विंडोज इवेंट लॉग सर्विसेस
होती हैं जो आपके सारे सिस्टम्स की
एक्टिविटीज और एरर्स को ट्रैक करके आपके
सिस्टम्स को प्रोवाइड करती रहती है उसके
बेसिस पर आपका सिस्टम ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डिसीजन लेता रहता है सेकंड होटल गेस्ट
डोंट सी और इंटरेक्ट विद द ल्री सर्विस
अभी जो ल्री सर्विस होती है कभी भी होटल
के गेस्ट कभी भी उनसे डायरेक्टली ना तो
इंटरेक्ट कर पाते डायरेक्टली आप क्या करते
हो इफ यू नीड एनी क्लोथ या वाशिंग योर
क्लोथ या आपको टावल ए डायरेक्टली कभी
इंटरेक्शन आपका लोडर सर्विस से होता ही
नहीं क्योंकि बट इसका मतलब नहीं कि वो काम
नहीं कर रहे वो काम कर रहे हैं इट इज
आल्सो एग्जांपल ऑफ ए बैकग्राउंड सर्विस
उसी प्रकार से विंडोज सर्विस डोंट हैव ए
विजिबल इंटरफेस लाइक एप्स उसी प्रकार से
जो आपकी विंडोज है उसका भी कोई भी विजिबल
इंटरफेस नहीं होता बाकी पप की जैसे कम है
वर्ड है बट दे परफॉर्म क्रिटिकल टास्क
बिहाइंड द सीन लेकिन बिहाइंड द सीन क्या
करते रहते हैं बहुत सारे क्रिटिकल टास्क
को वो परफॉर्म करते रहते हैं तो आई होप कि
जो सर्विसेस है और हमने एग्जांपल लिया
होटल के साथ तो यू आर क्लियर कि सर्विसेस
क्या हो सकती है हम सर्विसेस किनको बोल
सकते हैं तो सबको समझ में आ रहा है
एवरीवन ओके तो अनुभाव पोल तो आप मेरी
क्लास को लीव कर सकते हो अगर मेरा पढ़ाने
का तरीका बोर है तो मैंने आपको फोर्स नहीं
किया है कि आप मुझसे आइए और पढ़िए मैंने
आपसे रिक्वेस्ट नहीं की है ना ही हाथ पैर
जोड़े हैं अगर आपको क्लास को लीव करना आप
कर सकते
हो मैंने आपको नहीं फोर्स किया है आप अपनी
मर्जी से आए हो और आप इस तरह की कमेंट ना
करें यह सही रहेगा ओके किसी के पेशेंस को
कभी भी वो नहीं करना
चाहिए क्योंकि मुझे वैसे कोई इंटरेस्ट
नहीं आप में भी तो आपको पढ़ना तो पढ़िए
मैं आपसे कोई फीस नहीं ले रहा हूं मैं
जस्ट आता हूं अपनी क्लास पढ़ाता हूं देन
आई विल स्टॉप माय क्लास कभी मैंने आपको
फोर्स नहीं किया है तो डोंट ट्राई टू मेक
सम सच मैसेजेस
ओके ओके
चले नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं कि व्ट आर
विंडोज सर्विसेस अब विंडोज सर्विसेस होती
क्या
है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज सर्विसेस फॉर्मली
नोन एज एंटी सर्विसेस जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट की
जो विंडोज सर्विसेस है उनको हम एंटी
सर्विसेस बोलते हैं इनेबल यू टू क्रिएट
लॉन्ग रनिंग ए टेबल एप्लीकेशंस ट रन इन
देयर ओन विंडोज सेशन तो सबसे पहले हम
समझते हैं कि एंटी सर्विसेस होती क्या है
फेस कंप्लीट पैराग्राफ को हम समझने की
कोशिश करते हैं अभी व्हाट आर एंटी
सर्विसेस एंटी स्टैंड्स फॉर न्यू
टेक्नोलॉजी एंड वाज ए सीरीज ऑफ विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्टार्टिंग विद विंडोज
एटी 3.1
1993 एनटी का जो स्टैंड एनटी का जो मतलब
है न्यू टेक्नोलॉजी जिसको स्टार्ट किया था
किया गया था
windows.txt
3.1 से पहले जो ws9 5 था उसमें क्या कि था
कि अ सिक्योरिटी स्टेबिलिटी और मल्टी यूजर
स्पोर्ट की क्या थी थोड़ी कमिया थी तो
उसको और भी बेटर करने के लिए इसका इसको
डिजाइन किया गया था विंडोज एंटी को तो
एंटी सर्विसेस एक्चुअल में होती क्या है
देखो एंटी सर्विसेस व बैकग्राउंड
प्रोसेसेस दैट कुड स्टार्ट ऑटोमेटिक विद
विंडोज रन कंटीन्यूअसली एंड बी मैनेज
विदाउट यूजर इंटरेक्शन
ओके तो जो एंटी सर्विसेस है उनको हम
बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेस बोल सकते हैं जो आपके
विंडोज के साथ स्टार्ट होती है लगातार रन
करती हैं और बिना किसी यूजर इंटरेक्शन के
उनको मैनेज किया जाता है दज सर्विसेस वर
सिस्टम लेवल प्रोग्राम्स दैट परफॉर्म्स
टास्क सच एज नेटवर्क मैनेजमेंट सिक्योरिटी
प्रिंटिंग एंड अपडेट्स बेसिकली आपके
नेटवर्क को मैनेज करने के लिए सिक्योरिटी
प्रिंटिंग और भी बहुत सारी चीजें होती है
विंडोज के अंदर उनको मैनेज करने के लिए
इनको डिजाइन किया गया था अभी ओवर द टाइम्स
एंटी सर्विसेस बिकम सिंपली विंडोज
सर्विसेस अभी आप नाउ ए मॉडर्न डेज आप एंटी
सर्विसेस को आप विंडोज सर्विस बोलते हैं
अभी आपको बहुत रेयरली सुनने को मिलेगा कि
एंटी सर्विसेस लेकिन कभी आपको कोई एंटी
सर्विसेस नाम का वर्ड यूज करता है तो
सिंपली यू कैन से ओके ट्स मीन विंडोज
सर्विसेस तो कांसेप्ट बिल्कुल सेम है तो
अभी आते हैं हम अपने पैराग्राफ के कि
विंडोज माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज सर्विस
फॉर्मली नोन एज एंटी सर्विसेस सेल्फ
एक्सटरी इनेबल यू टू क्रिएट लॉन्ग रनिंग
एग्जीक्यूटेबल एप्लीकेशन दैट रन इन देयर
ओन विंडो सेशन ओके कि जो विंडोज सर्विसेस
हैं ये क्या करते हैं बहुत सारी
एप्लीकेशंस होती हैं एग्जीक्यूटेबल
एप्लीकेशंस होती है उनको उनके सेशंस के
अंदर रन करने के लिए एक कैपेबिलिटी
प्रोवाइड करते हैं दज सर्विसेस कैन बी
ऑटोमेटिक स्टार्टेड व्हेन कंप्यूटर बूड्स
दे कैन बी पोस्ट रीस्टार्ट एंड डू नॉट शो
एनी यूजर इंटरफेस सेल्फ एक्सट्री जब भी
किसी भी सर्विस को स्टार्ट किया जाता है
तो बहुत सारी सर्विसेस होती हैं जो सिस्टम
के बूट करते स्टार्ट हो जाती है कुछ
सिस्टम इनिला होने के बाद स्टार्ट हो जाती
है उनको पोज भी किया जा सकता है रीस्टार्ट
भी किया जा सकता है लेकिन कभी भी आपको कोई
भी यूजर इंटरफेस देखने को नहीं
मिलता दीज फीचर्स मेक सर्विसेस आइडियल फॉर
यूज ऑन ए सर्वर खास कर के जो सर्विसेस हैं
यह एक
अ वेरी गुड एग्जांपल या बहुत ही अच्छा यूज
केस है या आइडियल हो सकती हैं होती हैं
किसी भी सर्वर के लिए हो सकती नहीं होती
हैं किसी भी सर्वर के केस में जो सर्विसेस
हैं दे आर वेरी आइडियल आइडियल का मतलब
काफी बेनिफिशियल है व्हेन एवर यू नीड
लॉन्ग रनिंग फंक्शनल दैट डज नॉट इंटरफेयर
विद अदर यूजर्स हु आर वर्किंग ऑन द सेम
फॉर एग्जांपल आपका माइक्रोसॉफ्ट आईस सर्वर
है कौन सा जो वेब होस्टिंग के लिए यूज
किया जाता है वेबसाइट होस्ट करने के लिए
अब उसके लिए बहुत सारी सर्विसेस
बैकग्राउंड में रन करती है जो कभी भी किसी
भी यूजर को डिस्टर्ब नहीं करती और सर्वर
के केस में सारी की चीजें सारी की सारी
चीजें सॉरी सर्विसेस के फॉर्म में डील की
जाती है और दे आर वेरी गुड क्योंकि ना तो
उसका कोई अ इंटरफेयर इंटर इंटरफेस देखने
को मिलता और चुपचाप बैकग्राउंड में अपना
काम करते रहते हैं और आपका भी काम स्मूथ
हो जाता है थर्ड पॉइंट है यू कैन आल्सो रन
सर्विसेस इन द सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट ऑफ ए
स्पेसिफिक यूजर अकाउंट दैट इज डिफरेंट
फ्रॉम द लॉकडाउन यूजर्स और द डिफाल्ट
कंप्यूटर अकाउंट बेसिकली क्या है कि आप जो
सर्विसेस है उनको आप किसी भी स्पेसिफिक
यूजर अकाउंट के अकॉर्डिंग चाहे किसी भी
यूजर अकाउंट से लॉगिन किया हो लेकिन आप
किसी भी स्पेसिफिक य अकाउंट के अकॉर्डिंग
उनके सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट के अकॉर्डिंग
उनको रन करवा सकते हैं इसका मतलब क्या है
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड में समझते हैं देखिए
विंडोज सर्विसेस कैन रन इन डिफरेंट
सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट मतलब क्या है दे
कैन एग्जीक्यूट अंडर ए स्पेसिफिक यूजर
अकाउंट इंस्टेड ऑफ करेंटली लगड इन यूजर और
सिस्टम डिफाल्ट अकाउंट इसका कहने का मतलब
यह है कि आप जिस भी यूजर अकाउंट से लॉग इन
किया हुआ है उसकी बजाय और किसी भी दूसरे
यूजर अकाउंट से भी उनको क्या किया जा सकता
है लॉग इन किया जा सकता है एग्जीक्यूट
करवाया जा सकता है रदर देन आपके डिफॉल्ट
अकाउंट या लगड इन लॉग ऑन यूजर अकाउंट ओके
जिससे क्या होता है दिस प्रोवाइड्स बेटर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सेस कंट्रोल एंड फ्लेक्सिबल
फॉर मैनेजिंग सर्विसेस अभी बहुत सारे ऐसे
टास्क होते हैं कि आप एक नॉर्मल यूजर को
भी कुछ ऐसी सर्विसेस जो एडमिन यूजर के
द्वारा ही रन की जाती है लेकिन वो यूजर उस
परे डिपेंड करता है तोब सर्विसेस को उस
लेवल का एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करके या उस
स्पेसिफिक सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट के अंदर ये
परमिशन देकर उसको रन करवाया जा सकता है
व्हाट इज द सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट
सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट डिफाइंस द परमिश
एंड प्रिविलेजेस अंडर व्हिच ए सर्विस
ऑपरेट ओके अभी सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट का
मेरा मतलब होता है वो परमिश वो
प्रिविलेजेस जो किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्विसेस
को प्रोवाइड की जाती है जिसके अंदर वो
ऑपरेट करते हैं इफ ए सर्विस रन अंडर ए हाई
प्रिविलेज अकाउंट इट कैन एक्सेस क्रिटिकल
सिस्टम रिसोर्सेस ओबवियसली अगर आपके
सर्विस किसी ऐसे यूजर अकाउंट से रन कर रही
है जिसके पास हाई प्रिविलेज है एडमिन लेवल
के या एडमिन से ऊपर के भी प्रिविलेज हैं
तो वो आपके सिस्टम्स के क्रिटिकल से
क्रिटिकल रिसोर्स को भी एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं इफ ए सर्विस रन अंडर ए रिस्ट्रिक्टेड
अकाउंट इट हैज लिमिटेड एक्सेस एंड इंप्रूव
सिक्योरिटी व्हाई रन ए सर्विस अंडर ए
स्पेसिफिक यूजर अकाउंट हमें किसी भी एक
स्पेसिफिक यूजर अकाउंट के अंडर सर्विसेस
को रन करने की आवश्यकता क्यों होती है
इसके बहुत सारे कारण है सबसे पहला कारण है
कंट्रोल सम सर्विसेस नीड एक्सेस टू
स्पेसिफिक नेटवर्क ड्राइव्स डेटाबेस और
फाइल्स दैट आर ओनली अवेलेबल टू सर्टेन
यूजर्स तो एक्सेस कंट्रोल करने के लिए भी
हमें किसी भी एक स्पेसिफिक यूजर कांटेक्ट
के अगेंस्ट इसको सर्विसेस को रन करवाना
पड़ता है सिक्योरिटी बेस्ट प्रैक्टिसेस
रनिंग सर्विसेस विद लो प्रिविलेजेस
रिड्यूस द रिस्क ऑफ सिक्योरिटी ब्रीचेस इफ
ए सर्विस इज कंप्रोमाइज ऊपर से क्या है कि
अगर आप सर्विसेस पर कंट्रोल कर पा रहे हैं
उनकी परमिशन
प्रिविलेजेस पे तो इसका मतलब क्या है कि
आपका जो सिस्टम है वोह कंप्रोमाइज होने से
भी बच सकता है क्योंकि दे आर द प्राइम
टारगेट फॉर एनी पन टेस्टर्स फॉर द
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन और इवन फॉर ए पर्सिस
एक्सेस सेपरेशन ऑफ द रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज की
बात करते हैं सम कंपनीज यूज डिफरेंट
अकाउंट टू कंट्रोल एक्सेस टू सेंसिटिव
डाटा फॉर एग्जांपल एक कंपनी एक फाइनेंसियल
कंपनी है वो एक सर्विस प्रोवाइड करती है
आपको सेंसिटिव रिपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करती है
आपकी फाइनेंसियल रिपोर्ट तोब उसने क्या
किया है कि अपनी सर्विसेस को मतलब
फाइनेंसियल रिपोर्ट करनी है रिपोर्ट जनरेट
करनी है तो उसके लिए ऐसा तो नहीं है कि वह
सिस्टम लेवल के प्रिविलेज दे देंगे उ उस
सर्विस को तो उन्होंने किया कि एक अलग से
फाइनेंस सर्विस अकाउंट नाम का एक ग्रुप
क्रिएट किया है और जो जो सर्विसेस की
रिक्वायरमेंट है फाइनेंस रिपोर्ट जनरेट
करने के लिए उस ग्रुप का पार्ट बना दिया
और उस लेवल के एक्सेस है उसको और वह अपना
काम स्मूथली कर पा रहे हैं रदर देन आपने
उसको फुल कंट्रोल देने की बजाय अभी उसका
जो एक्सेस है वो ओनली लिमिटेड टू दिस
सर्विस ओनली फाइनेंशियल रिपोर्टिंग सर्विस
ओके अननेसेसरी आपने फुल सिस्टम को का
प्रिविलेजेस उसको प्रोवाइड नहीं किए फुल
एक्सेस प्रोवाइड नहीं किया तो दैट इज
कॉल्ड सर्विसेस तो आई होप कि सबको समझ में
आ गया होगा कि विंडोज की टर्म में
सर्विसेस होती क्या है ओके यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है
स्टार्ट करें आगे कंटिन्यू करें
क्या बताना बताओ सर क्या बताना एक बार और
क्या रिपीट करना मुझे यह
बताइए बताइए आपको क्या पूछना है क्या
जानना
है सिक्योरिटी कॉन्टेक्स्ट क्या होता है
देख देखिए फॉर
एग्जांपल किसी भी यूजर्स को अगर मैंने
आपका जो विंडोज मशीन होगी या
भी परमिशन और प्रिविलेजेस हैं अब सर्विसेस
को भी रन करने के लिए अकाउंट की जरूरत मैं
बताऊंगा आगे भी बताऊंगा कि जो सर्विसेस
हैं सर्विसेस कुछ प्री डिफाइड अकाउंट के
अंदर ही रन करती है और हर हर एक अकाउंट के
अपने प्रिविलेजेस और परमिशन होती है
क्योंकि अगर आपके सर्विस को वो प्रिविलेज
चाहिए ही नहीं हाई लेवल के हाईएस्ट
प्रिविलेजेस मतलब आपका पूरा रूट एक्सेस
आपको रूट लेवल के प्रिविलेज अगर आपके
सर्विस को रन करने के लिए चाहिए ही नहीं
तो आपको वह परमिशन और प्रिविलेजेस उसको
देने ही क्यों है तो सबको क्या करने के
लिए कंट्रोल करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं
सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट का यूज करते हैं
सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट एक टर्म है लेकिन जब
भी आपको कोई सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट बोलता है
समझ लीजिए कि यहां पर किसी भी स्पेसिफिक
चीज के लिए परमिश या प्रिविलेजेस की बात
हो रही
है ओके
नाउ अभी आपको सर्विसेस देखनी है तो सिंपली
आपको क्या करना
है आपको सिंपली गो टू योर विंडो आर प्रेस
करना है यहां पर आपको क्या करना है लिखना
है
सर्विसेस एसई
आ सर्विसेस डॉट
एमएससी
देखिए यह सारी आपकी क्या है सर्विसेस है
आप भी क्या कर सकते हो अपनी मशीन के अंदर
देख सकते हो सिंपली विंडो सविस एमसी देखिए
यहां पर बहुत सारी सर्विसेस रनिंग है बहुत
सारी मैनुअल है देखिए ऑटोमेटिक मैनुअल
देखिए मैनुअल कुछ रनिंग है कुछ बहुत सारी
मैनुअल है अभी देखिए ट्रिगर स्टार्ट प कुछ
मैनुअल और ट्रिगर स्टार्ट पर है सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है य पर क्लियर है कि यहां
पर आप सर्विसेस देख सकते हो सबको दिखाई दे
रहा
है देखिए क्या होता है कि बहुत सारी
सर्विसेस देखो सारी की सारी सर्विसेस रन
नहीं करती ठीक है जितनी रिक्वायरमेंट है
उतनी सर्विसेस आपकी रन करवाई जाती है बाकी
जो मैनुअल प रहती हैं वो वेट करती है किसी
पर्टिकुलर इवेंट का ट्रिगर होने के लिए कि
जैसे ही उस सर्विस के अगेंस्ट कोई इवेंट
या उस सर्विस को ट्रिगर किया जाएगा या उस
सर्विस को को रिक्वेस्ट किया जाएगा तभी उस
सर्विस को रन किया जाएगा क्योंकि जो
सर्विसेस क्या है एक प्रोसेस है और एक
प्रोसेस को रिक्वायरमेंट क्या होती है
मेमोरी की मेमोरी क्या होता है रम तो अगर
आप अननेसेसरी सारी की सारी सर्विसेस को रन
कर दोगे तो आपकी रम भर जाएगी अगर आपकी रैम
भरेगी रैम कंजप्शन ज्यादा होगा तो आपका जो
सिस्टम्स है वो स्लो हो जाएगा दैट इज
व्हाई ओनली रिक्वायर्ड सर्विसेस रनिंग
होती है अदर वाइज जो बाकी नवल्स है या
ट्रिगर स्टार्ट है जैसे उसके अगेंस्ट कोई
अ रिक्वेस्ट की जाती है या उस अग जो भी
इवेंट सेट किया गया जैसे वो इवेंट ट्रिगर
होता है वो सर्विसेस रन कर जाती
है ओके कुछ ऑटोमेटिक होती है जो आपके
सिस्टम के स्टार्टअप पर काम करती हैं ओके
अभी और भी आगे चीज में बता देता हूं
नाउ स्लाइड पर चलते
हैं अभी होता क्या है कि जो 90 पर ऑफ द
सर्विसेस आर क्रिएट एंड इंस्टॉल्ड बाय
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट जो 90 पर जो सर्विसेस होती
हैं वो आपके माइक्रोसॉफ्ट के द्वारा
इंस्टॉल और क्रिएट की जाती है क्योंकि
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने सब कुछ इतना फास्ट और
इतना स्मूथली यूजर फ्रेंडली ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इसलिए है क्योंकि माइक्रोसॉफ्ट को
पता है कि मैक्सिमम एप्लीकेशन वो पहले से
ही आपके साथ इंस्टॉल कर देता है लेकिन
जिनकी रिक्वायरमेंट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
साथ स्टार्ट होने की है उनको रन कर देता
है बाकी को मैनुअल इवेंट प सेट करते तो
जैसे ही उस सर्विस को ट्रिगर किया जाएगा
किसी भी एप्लीकेशन के के द्वारा वो सर्विस
रन कर जाएगी ओके लेकिन जो 10 पर बच की
थर्ड पार्टी सर्विसेस भी अवेलेबल होती हैं
अगर वो भी आप देखना चाहते हो तो भी आप देख
सकते हो विंडो आर एमएस कॉन्फिडो आर आप देख
सकते हो मैं इसको क्लोज करता हूं विंडो और
आर एमएस
कॉन्फिन फिग करोगे आप अपनी विंडो के अंदर
हिट एंटर और आप देखिए यहां पर आपको सिंपली
गो टू सर्विस टैब यह देखिए अब ये इससे
बड़ा नहीं होगा क् इसको मैं जूम भी नहीं
कर सकता देख
मैन्युफैक्चरर देखिए यह एर के द्वारा बनाई
गई देखो थर्ड पार्टी है देखो 13d
टेक्नोलॉजी एर एर अी देखो बहुत सारी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट देखिए
जब आपकी एप्लीकेशन को इंस्टॉल किया जाता
है उसके साथ ही आती है व ओके देखिए ये
रहा यहां
पर सबको दिखाई दे रहा है सबको दिखाई दे
गया यहां पर सब कुछ क्लियर
है सबको यहां तक क्लियर
है बताइए
ओके चलो अभी नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प चलते हैं
अभी मैं कंपैरिजन करूं अगर विज 11 का और
विज सर्वर 2020 का तो जब भी विज 11 आपका
इंस्टॉल होता है
और आप इंस्टॉल करते हो अपनी मशीन के अंदर
तो बाय डिफॉल्ट उसके पास 200 या 200 के
अराउंड सर्विसेस प्री इंस्टॉल्ड आती है
200 सर्विस के प्रीइंस्टॉल वहीं पर अगर
मैं बात करता हूं
[संगीत]
ws623 सर्विस के आसपास की सर्विसेस प्री
इंस्टॉल आती है ऐसा क्यों की बात करता हूं
तो उसकी 1/4 सर्विसेस इंस्टॉल होके आती है
क्यों क्योंकि जो आपके सर्वर्स होते हैं
वह सीएआई सीएआई होती है कमांड लाइन
इंटरफेस पे काम करते हैं क्योंकि जो सर्वर
है जीआई मोड पे काम नहीं करते खास करके
ज्यादातर सर्वर तो इसलिए सर्वर के केस में
सर्विसेस आपको कम देखने को मिलती है लेकिन
आपके जो विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम नॉर्मल
उनके ऊपर सर्विसेस ज्यादा देखने को मिलती
है दैट इज अ वेरी स्मॉल कंपेरिजन ऑफ द
सर्विसेस नाउ अभी एक आपको जो डायग्राम
देखने को मिल रहा है ये एक बेसिक विंडोज
की एंटी न्यू टेक्नोलॉजी आर्किटेक्चर का
डि डायग्राम है जिसमें आपको दो मोड देखने
को मिल रहे एक तो कनल मोड कनल मोड में ऐसी
बहुत सारी चीजें होती है और यह यूजर मोड
होता है कनल मोड में कनल मोड की सारी
चीजें होती है कनल लेवल की हार्डवेयर लेवल
की और यूजर मेड मोड का जो मतलब होता है
आपके यूजर से तो इसको समझाने की कोशिश
करता हूं इन एन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अग किसी
भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की बात करता हूं मैं
कि यूजर स्पेस इज द मेमोरी रीजन वेर ऑल
यूजर मोड एप्लीकेशन एंड सर्विसेस
एग्जीक्यूट जहां पर जितने भी यूजर की
एप्लीकेशन या सर्विसेस है एग्जीक्यूट करती
है यूजर स्पेस के अंदर ध्यान रखिए या तो
आपकी यूजर्स एप्लीकेशन या आपके सर्विसेस
या उसके जो बोल सकते हो आप सिस्टम
प्रोसेसेस ही रन करती है इट इज आइसोलेटेड
फ्रॉम द सिस्टम कर्नल स्पेस टू इंश्योर
स्टेबिलिटी सिक्योरिटी एंड एफिशिएंसी इसको
जो कर्नल स्पेस है उससे आइसोलेट किया गया
है ताकि अगर किसी भी एप्लीकेशन में
प्रॉब्लम होगी तो वो कर्नल को इंटरफेयर ना
कर पाए किसी भी कारण से ऑल सर्विसेस
एप्लीकेशंस एंड इवन सिस्टम प्रोसेसेस इन
एंड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑपरेट इन यूजर स्पेस
अनलेस दे नीड डायरेक्ट कनल फ्लस जब तक वो
कनल स्पेस में रन नहीं कर सकती जब तक उसके
पास डायरेक्ट कर्नल लेवल के प्रिविलेजेस
नहीं होंगे किसी भी सर्विस किसी भी सिस्टम
प्रोसेस या एप्लीकेशन के पास ओके सारी के
सारी सर्विसेस एप्लीकेशंस और सिस्टम
प्रोसेसेस आपकी किसके अंदर रन करती है
यूजर स्पेस के अंदर दिस सेपरेशन एन हैंस
सिस्टम स्टेबिलिटी सिक्योरिटी परफॉर्मेंस
बाय प्रीवेंटिंग एक्सीडेंटल इंटरफेस विद
कोर सिस्टम ऑपरेशंस
हाउ एवर दे इज अ क्लियर डिस्टिंक्शन
बिटवीन इंटरेक्ट एप्लीकेशन ब्राउजर विद
मल्टी प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर एंड बैकग्राउंड
सर्विसेस दैट रन पर्सिस मेंटली टू स्पोर्ट
सिस्टम फंक्शन वही चीज है दो ऊपर की दो
लाइनों में मैंने आपको समझाया वही चीज है
कि यूजर मोड के अंदर सारी सिस्टम प्रोसेस
सर्विसेस और एप्लीकेशंस रन करती हैं लेकिन
कर्नल मोड के अंदर ओनली कर्नल से रिलेटेड
जो चीजें हैं वोह काम करती
ठीक है कोई भी एप्लीकेशन कोई भी सिस्टम
प्रोसेस या कोई भी सर्विसेस कर्नल मोड के
अंदर रन नहीं करती अनटिल और अनलेस उसके
पास कर्नल लेवल के प्रिविलेजेस नहीं है
ओके अभी हम बात करते हैं कि हु कंट्रोल द
सर्विसेस ओके सर्विसेस आपको समझ में आ गई
सर्विसेस होती क्या है लेकिन सर्विसेस को
कोई कंट्रोल तो करता होगा ना कोई तो माय
बाप होगा इनका तो सर्विसेस आर कंट्रोल्ड
बाय एससीएम सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर आपके
सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर द्वारा कंट्रोल की
जाती है द सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर इन
विंडोज इज ए क्रिटिकल कंपोनेंट ऑफ द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग
सर्विसेस इट इज अ वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट और
इट इज वेरी वेरी क्रिटिकल कंपोनेंट जो
आपकी सारी की सारी सर्विसेस को क्या करता
है मैनेज करता
है जो एससीएम है इसकी कुछ
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज होती है जिसके बार में
डिस्कस एससीएम इज ए सिस्टम प्रोसेस एससीएम
क्या है जो सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर है एक
सिस्टम प्रोसेस है है जो आप अपने प्रोसेस
एक्सप्लोरर के अंदर भी देख सकते हो सर्विस
डसी के नाम से ट एक्ट एज ए सेंट्रल
कंट्रोलर फॉर ऑल विंडो सर्विसेस सारी की
सारी विंडो सर्विसेस के लिए एक कंट्रोलर
का काम करता है जैसे आपकी प्रोसेस को
शेड्यूल करने के लिए शेड्यूलर शेड्यूलर एक
कंट्रोलर काम करता है उसी प्रकार विंडोज
सर्विसेस को को रन करने के लिए वो करने के
लिए ठीक है वह क्या करता है एक एससीएम है
कंट्रोलर का काम करता है सेंटर कंट्रोलर
तो इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग सर्विस
लाइफ साइकिल वो क्या करता है आपके सर्विस
की लाइफ साइकिल को मैनेज करता है उसको
स्टार्ट करना स्टॉप करना पोज करना रिज्यूम
करना एटस हैंडलिंग डिपेंडेंसी बिटवीन
सर्विसेस अब सर्विसेस के बीच में भी
डिपेंडेंसी हो एक सर्विस को रन करने के
लिए के लिए उसको दूसरी सर्विसेस की भी
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है तो उनकी भी क्या
होती है डिपेंडेंट डिपेंडेंसीज होती हैं
तो उनको भी हैंडल कौन करता है एचसीएम
कंट्रोलिंग सर्विस एक्सेस एंड सिक्योरिटी
सेटिंग अब जो सर्विसेस है उसके एक्सेस और
सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग को भी क्या करता है
कंट्रोल करता है रीस्टार्ट फेल्ड सर्विसेस
एज पर कन्फर रिकवरी सेटिंग अभी कोई भी
सर्विस है जब उसको सेट किया जाता है उसको
कंफिल किया जाता है तो उसके लिए एक पाथ
सेट किया जाता है अगर आपकी सर्विस फेल हुई
तो क्या करना है आपके एससीएम को सिस्टम को
रीस्टार्ट करना है या उस सर्विस को
रीस्टार्ट करना है या उसकी रिकवरी एक
स्क्रिप्ट है उसको रन करना है ओके तो सारी
चीजें की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी आपके एससीएम की
होती है इन केस ऑफ ए सर्विस क्योंकि
सर्विस पर पूरा कंट्रोल आपके सर्विस
कंट्रोल मैनेजर का
है नेक्स्ट सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर समझ में
आ गया और भी डीप में जाएंगे इसमें
क्लियर
ओके अभी एचसीएम होता क्या
है एससी मतलब ओके हाउ एससीएम वर्क्स
एससीएम काम कैसे करता है स्टेप वन एचसीएम
प्रोसेस
स्टार्टस सबसे पहले क्या होता है एससीएम
की प्रोसेस स्टार्ट होती है सर्विसेस ड इ
एज ए सिस्टम प्रोसेस बाय द सेशन मैनेजर सब
सिस्टम सबको पता है जैसे ही कर्नल की प्र
कर्नल अपना एग्जीक्यूशन कंप्लीट करता है
इनिला इजेशन कंप्लीट करता है ड्यूरिंग बूट
प्रोसेस उसके बाद सबसे पहले जो यूजर मोड
की प्रोसेस होती है कौन सी होती थी सेशन
मैनेजर यह प्रोसेस इसको स्टार्ट करती है
आपकी सर्विसेस डसी को एक प्रोसेस यह है
सर्विस इसको य स्टार्ट कि करती है सेशन
मैनेजर इट रस विद सिस्टम प्रिविलेजेस एंड
इ रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग ऑल बिल्ड और
विंडो सर्विसेस अभी जो एससीएम है एससीएम
के पास कौन से कौन से प्रिविलेजेस होते
हैं आपके सिस्टम लेवल के प्रिविलेजेस होते
हैं और आपकी विंडोज के ऊपर सबसे पावरफुल
जो प्रिविलेजेस है वो किसके पास आपके
सिस्टम के पास है यह वाले प्रिविलेज तो
आपके एडमिन के पास भी नहीं है उसके बाद
एससीएम स्कैन द सर्विसेस रजिस्ट्री सबसे
पहले आपकी एससीएम की प्रोसेस स्टार्ट होती
है उसके बाद जो सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर है
वो
सर्विस रजिस्ट्री को स्कैन करती है एससीएम
स्टोर्स एंड रिट्रीव सर्विस कॉन्फिन
डिटेल्स फ्रॉम द विंडोज रजिस्ट्री लोकेशन
कहां पर आपकी एच की लोकल मशीन सिस्टम करंट
कंट्रोल सेट ये एक रजिस्ट्री की लोकेशन है
यहां से आपकी रजिस्ट्री को स्कैन करती है
और इसके अंदर जितनी भी सर्विसेस हैं जितनी
भी सर्विस रिलेटेड कन्फेशन की गई है सबकी
इंफॉर्मेशन को वन बाय वन स्टोर करती है
रिट्रीव करती है और अपने लोकल डेटाबेस
एससीएम का भी एक डेटाबेस होता है है उसको
मेंटेन करती है उसमें स्टोर करती है ईच
एंट्री इज एडेड टू द डेटाबेस एंड इज
कंसीडर्ड एज ए सर्विस रिकॉर्ड उसको एक
सर्विस रिकॉर्ड के रूप में कंसीडर किया
जाता है एससीएम के द्वारा एवरी रिकॉर्ड
विल हैव द नेम ऑफ द सर्विस एंड इज को
रिलेटिंग
पैरामीटर्स ओके अब जो जो हर एक एंट्री है
एवरी एंट्री इज एडेड टू द डेटाबेस हर एक
एंट्री को क्या है उसके डेटाबेस में ऐड
किया जाता है और हर एक रिकॉर्ड हर एक को
एक सर्विस रिकॉर्ड के रूप में कंसीडर किया
जाता है ईच सर्विस रिकॉर्ड कंटेंस कन्फेशन
पैरामीटर्स अभी जो रजिस्ट्री है उसके अंदर
किस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन रहती है डिस्प्ले
नेम इमेज पाथ स्टार्ट टाइप डिपेंड ऑन
सर्विस और ऑब्जेक्ट नेम डिस्प्ले नेम का
मतलब उसका नेम क्या है सर्विसेस का इमेज
पाथ का मतलब फुल पाथ वो जो बाइनरी फाइल है
उसका फुल पाथ क है कहां से उस सर्विसेस को
लोड करना है एग्जीक्यूट करना है स्टार्ट
ऑटोमेटिक स्टार्ट होगी मैनुअल है या उसको
डिसेबल किया गया टाइप किस टाइप की वो
सर्विस है वि 32 है या कोई ड्राइवर सर्विस
है या व्हाट एवर डिपेंड ऑन सर्विस इस
सर्विस की कोई डिपेंडेंसी तो नहीं है
ऑब्जेक्ट नेम किस अकाउंट के अंदर इसको रन
किया जाएगा क्योंकि सर्विस को भी रन करने
के लिए अकाउंट की आवश्यकता होती है जरूरत
होती है तो स्टेप स्टेप टू में क्या होता
है एससीएम ि सर्विस रजिस्ट्री को स्कैन
करता है और वहां से डाटा को रिट्रीव करता
है रिट्रीव करके अपने डेटाबेस में स्टोर
करता है स्टेप थ्री में क्या होता है
एससीएम क्रिएट द सर्विस डेटाबेस एससीएम
क्या क्या करता है खुद का सर्विस डेटाबेस
क्रिएट करता है फॉर एवरी सर्विस रजिस्ट्री
एंट्री एससीएम क्रिएट एन इंटरनल रिकॉर्ड
एंड ऐड इट टू द सर्विस डेटाबेस एंड दिस
सर्विस डेटाबेस इज स्टोर्ड इन मेमोरी एंड
यूज्ड फॉर ट्रैकिंग ऑल द इंस्टॉल सर्विसेस
अभी ये जो डेटा बेस एससीएम का इसको जो
आपकी रैम है उसके अंदर स्टोर किया जाता है
और बाकी जितनी भी सर्विसेस है उसको ट्रैक
करने के लिए एक रेफरेंस बना लिया जाता है
पहले से ही अब इस डेटाबेस के पास
क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है आपके
सर्विस का नाम उसका एग्जीक्यूटेबल पाथ
उसका स्टेटस रनिंग स्टॉप पोज किस टाइप की
सर्विस है और उसका स्टार्टअप टाइप ये सारी
उस डेटाबेस के पास इंफॉर्मेशन होगी रैम के
अंदर स्टेप फोर में एससीएम क्या करता है
डिटरमाइंड सर्विस एग्जीक्यूशन ऑर्डर ओके
स्टेप फोर में डिटरमाइंड कर कि आपके जो
सर्विस है
उसको एग्जीक्यूट या उसको ऑन कैसे किया
जाएगा एससीएम चेक ईच सर्विस स्टार्ट
वैल्यू ये जो सर्विस स्टार्ट टाइप है ना
इस वैल्यू को चेक करता है रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर डिटर माइन व्हिच सर्विस नीड टू
स्टार्ट ए बूट कौन सी सर्विस बूट टाइम पर
स्टार्ट होगी कौन सी सर्विस सिस्टम
स्टार्टअप पर स्टार्ट होगी देखिए यहां पर
जीरो है तो बूट टाइम पर स्टार्ट होगी वन
सिस्टम मतलब लोडेड बाय कर्नल बट मैनेज बाय
एचसीएम अगर टू है ऑटोमेटिक जहां पर आपने
देखा था ऑटोमेटिक आपने देखा था अभी मैनुअल
और ऑटोमेटिक तो अगर वहां पर वैल्यू दो है
मतलब सिस्टम इनिश इज होने के बाद ऑटोमेटिक
सर्विस को स्टार्ट कर दिया जाएगा अगर
मैनुअल है तो उस वो किसी ट्रिगर इवेंट का
वेट करेगी ओके उसको जब ट्रिगर किया जाएगा
तभी उस सर्विस को स्टार्ट किया जाएगा
डिसेबल्ड है मतलब उसको स्टार्ट नहीं किया
जाएगा कैन नॉट बी स्टार्ट उसको स्टार्ट
नहीं करना है ओके तो स्टार्ट वैल्यू रहती
है स्टार्ट अप टाइप के अंदर इस वैल्यू को
देख के यह डिटरमाइंड करता है कि किस ऑर्डर
में सर्विस को एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा जो
स्टेप फाइव होता है उसके बाद एचसीएम उसकी
डिपेंडेंसी को रिजॉल्व करता है एचसीएम रीट
द डिपेंड ऑन सर्विस की मैंने आपको दिखाया
था यह
रहा डिपेंड ऑन सर्विस की तो एससीएम क्या
करता है इस की को रीड करता है फॉर ईच
सर्विस टू चेक डिपेंडेंसीज कि किसी सर्विस
की डिपेंडेंसीज तो नहीं है इफ सर्विस
डिपेंड ऑन द अनदर सर्विस इट वुड नॉट
स्टार्ट अंट्स इ रनिंग तब तक उस सर्विस को
स्टार्ट नहीं करे जब तक वो डिपेंडेंसी
रिजॉल्व ना हो जाए तब तक वो वो सर्विस रन
ना हो जाए उससे जिसके ऊपर डिपेंड करती है
बिकॉज सम सर्विसेस डिपेंड ऑन द अदर टू
फंक्शन प्रॉपर्ली एंड इंश्योर डिपेंडेंसीज
आर स्टार्ट फर्स्ट एड सबसे पहले
डिपेंडेंसी को स्टार्ट किया जाएगा देन
ओनली उसी पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को स्टार्ट
किया जाएगा अगर वोह सर्विसेस किसी के ऊपर
डिपेंड करती है तो एससीएम लच ऑटो स्टार्ट
सर्विस उसके बाद सबसे पहले जो एससीएम है
ऑटो स्टार्ट सर्विसेस को लच करता है आफ्टर
रिजॉल्विंग डिपेंडेंसीज एससीएम स्टार्ट ऑल
ऑटो स्टार्ट सर्विसेस सर्विसेस आर
एग्जीक्यूटेड यूजिंग द इमेज पाथ बाइनरी
स्पेसिफाइड इन द रजिस्ट्री ओके देन उसके
बाद स्टेप सेवन में जब सर्विसेस स्टार्ट
हो जाती हैं उसके बाद सर्विसेस म मटर भी
किसका करने का काम भी किसका है एचसीएम
एचसीएम जितनी भी सर्विसेस रन करती है सबको
मॉनिटर भी करता है इसलिए टोटली कंट्रोल
किसके पास है सर्विसेस का एससीएम के पास
एससीएम कंटीन्यूअसली मॉनिटर द स्टेटस ऑफ द
रनिंग सर्विसेस इफ ए सर्विस क्रैश और
स्टॉप
अनएक्सपेक्टेडली एससीएम फॉलो द फेलियर
रिकवरी एक्शन डिफाइंड इन द रजिस्ट्री जैसे
उसको रीस्टार्ट करना है या उस प्रोग्राम
को रन करना है या स्पेसिफिक स्क्रिप्ट को
रन करना है उसको रिबूट करना पूरे सिस्टम
को रिबूट करना है ये सारे के सारे आप की
उसके अंदर रिकवरी ऑप्शन के अंदर सेट मिलता
है सर्विसेस तो एससीएम सबको समझ में आ गया
यहां
तक यहां तक एचसीएम क्या होता है और एचसीएम
काम कैसे करता है एवरीवन गट क्लियर
ओके यहां तक सबको क्लियर है एक बार बताओ
सब सभी बताइए एक बार प्लीज चैट में जल्दी
से बताइए उसके बाद कंटिन्यू करते हैं सबको
एसीएम समझ में आ
गया एवरीवन दे ओनली 10 टू 15 स्टूडेंट्स
तो प्लीज एवरीवन टू एवरीवन
ओके नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम अभी जो सर्विसेस
है सर्विसेस को भी रन करने के लिए अकाउंट
की जरूरत होती है सर्विसेस नीड्स अकाउंट
टू रन ठीक है अब सर्विसेस अकाउंट आर ए
स्पेशल टाइप ऑफ नॉन ह्यूमन प्रज अकाउंट जो
सर्विस होते हैं व जिस भी अकाउंट को यूज
करते हैं वे एक स्पेशल टाइप के अकाउंट
होते हैं दैट इज कॉल्ड नॉन ह्यूमन
प्रिविलेज अकाउंट यूज टू क्यूट एप्लीकेशंस
एंड रन ऑटोमेटेड सर्विस वर्चुअल मशीन
इंस्टेंस एंड अदर प्रोसेसेस अनलाइक रेगुलर
यूजर सर्विस अकाउंट डू नॉट बिलोंग टू ए
फिजिकल पर्सन दे डू नॉट हैव इंटरेक्ट
लॉगइन एक्सेस मीनिंग दे कैन नॉट बी यूज टू
लॉग इन इन टू द सिस्टम
डायरेक्टली बेसिकली हम कह सकते हैं कि जो
सर्विसेस जिन अकाउंट को यूज करते हैं उनके
साथ आप इंटरेक्ट नहीं कर सकते उनकी हेल्प
से आप सिस्टम में लॉग इन नहीं कर सकते
एक्सेप्ट कुछ स्पेशल केसेस हो सकते हैं
ठीक है अदर वाइज आप उन अकाउंट की हेल्प से
सिस्टम्स में ना तो उन अकाउंट को आप किसी
को असाइन कर सकते नाउन अकाउंट्स में आप
लॉग इन कर सकते ओके दे एजिस्ट ओनली एजिस्ट
ओनली टू रन सर्विसेस एप्लीकेशन एंड सिस्टम
टैक्स ओके वो ओनली
सर्विसेस ओके तो वो ओनली सर्विसेस
एप्लीकेशन या सिस्टम टास्क के लिए ही
डिजाइन किए जाते हैं ओके नेक्स्ट लेट्स सी
प्रैक्टिकली अगर आपको प्रैक्टिकली देखना
है तो अगर देखो अब कौन-कौन से अकाउंट हो
उसके बारे में तो मैं बताऊंगा ही बताऊंगा
तो एक चीज जाइए फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी गो
बैक एंड राइट क्लिक एंड ये हमारा टास्क
मैनेजर है टास्क मैनेजर मैंने ओपन किया
अभी फॉर एग्जांपल यह मेरी सर्विसेस रन कर
रही है मैं सर्विसेस के ऊपर जाता हूं मैं
खास स्क्रोल डाउन स्क्रोल डाउन स्क्रोल
डाउन ये ही विंडोज प्रोसेसेस है ये मेरी
सारी सर्विसेस है देखो सर्विस सोस
फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने ये वर्क स्टेशन
है य रहा ये रहा कोई भी है विंडोज टाइम है
यहां पर मैंने राइट क्लिक किया और गो टू
डिटेल्स मैं डिटेल्स पे गया यहां पर
हाईलाइट होगी सर्वि एसवीसी होस्टड एक ये
इसकी पी आईडी है रनिंग है अभी यहां पर
देखिए अब इसको मैं क्या कर सकता हूं राइट
क्लिक गो टू एक
मिनट इसका एक पाथ था आई राइट डाउन सम वेयर
यह रहा गो टू सर्विसेस आपको क्या करना है
यहां पर गो टू सर्विसेस पर जाना है अभी ये
देखो इसकी सर्विसेस कौन सी है w32 टाइम
ओके अभी यहां पर देख सकते हो वैसे य किस
ग्रुप से बिलोंग करता है देखो रनिंग है और
लोकल सर्विस इस ग्रुप से ये बिलोंग करता
है फिर से राइट क्लिक गो टू ओपन सर्विसेस
गो टू ओपन सर्विसेस प आपको जाना है यह
आपका सर्विस टैप हो w33 था इसको सर्च करना
है w32 तो उसको हम सर्च करते हैं ड 32 वे
इ द
w32 वे इ द सर्विस ओके यही था ना हमारा
w32 टाइम विंडोज टाइम एंड एंड एंड w32
टाइम यहीं पर
होगी ये रहा विंडोज टाइम है ये देखो रनिंग
है मैनुअल है देखिए यहां पर एक चीज देखिए
लॉग ऑन एज इस सर्विस का अकाउंट है ये देखो
लोकल सर्विस इस सर्विस का यह अकाउंट है
अगर इस पर राइट क्लिक करके इसकी
प्रॉपर्टीज को भी चेक करता हूं यहां पर
देखो आपको दिखाया था यह इसकी डिटेल्स है
यह इसका पाथ है देखिए इमेज पाथ है जो मैं
आपको बताया था सर्विस टाइप मैनुअल ओके लग
ऑन देखिए यहां पर देख सकते हो लोकल अकाउंट
सेटिंग या कौन सी सर्विस है देखो उसका
रिकवरी ऑप्शन भी रहता है इन देखो पहली बार
फेल हुआ तो सर्विस को रि स्टार्ट करना है
सेकंड टाइम फे हुआ तो फिर से सर्विस को रि
स्टार्ट करना है लगातार फेल हो तो इसके
लिए कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट या एक्शन डिसाइड
नहीं है ओके तो ये देखिए मैं जो चीज आपको
बताया था सारी चीज प्रैक्टिकली दिखा रहा
हूं तो अभी इन सर्विसेस के अकाउंट होते
हैं तो ये अकाउंट कौन-कौन से होते हैं और
इनके क्या-क्या प्रोलीज होते हैं मैं
बताता हूं आपको क्योंकि यह आपको काम आएंगे
जब आप लैटरल मूवमेंट या आप विंडोज
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
करोगे प्रोफेशन लेवल पर तब ये सारी चीजें
जैसे आपको दिखेगी उसी हिसाब से आपका
रिएक्शन होना चाहिए आपको इसलिए ये
इंफॉर्मेशन इंपोर्टेंट है नाउ क्लोज द टैब
देन अगेन अभी फॉर एग्जांपल अगर आप उसके
अंदर जाते हो अपने विंडोज के अंदर सीएमडी
सीएमडी के अंदर जाके आप हु एम आई और यह
टाइप करना तो हर एक अकाउंट की विंडोज के
अंदर कुछ प्रिविलेजेस असाइन किए जाते हैं
तो एवरी अकाउंट इन विंडोज हैज प्रिविलेजेस
असाइन टू ट अकाउंट क्यों क्योंकि दिस इज द
फंडामेंटल कंस्ट्रक्ट फॉर सिक्योरिटी इन
आवर ऑप सिस्टम हमारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
अंदर सबसे पहली जो फंडामेंटल सिक्योरिटी
रिक्वायरमेंट है वोह है किसी भी यूजर्स को
कंट्रोल करना कंट्रोल करने के लिए उसपे हम
क्या लगाते हैं परमिशन और प्रिविलेजेस
सर्विस अकाउंट ऑफें हैव हायर प्रिविलेजेस
देन रेगुलर यूजर अकाउंट अभी जो सर्विस
अकाउंट होते हैं उनके पास रेगुलर यूजर
अकाउंट से ज्यादा प्रिविलेजेस होते हैं
बिकॉज दे नीड एक्सेस टू सिस्टम फाइल्स
नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स
फॉर एग्जांपल विज हैज मेनी बैकग्राउंड
सर्विसेस लाइक विंडोज डिफेंडर विंडोज
अपडेट एटस व्हिच आर ऑटोमेटेड एंड रन
विदाउट हूमन इंटरवेंशन कभी भी आपने देखा
कि आप विंडो को रन कर रहे हो और सडन आपको
विंडोज डिफेंडर का कोई प्रोमट आया कि ओके
मुझे विंडोज डिफेंडर रन करना है विंडोज का
अपडेट के लिए प्रोमट आया नहीं आया आपने
ऑटोमेटिक अगर उसको इनेबल किया है तो
ऑटोमेटिक बैकग्राउंड में वो आपको
प्रोटेक्ट करता रहता है उसको आपको अपडेट
करता रहता है कभी भी आपके सामने कोई भी
इंटरफेस नहीं आता आपको डिस्टर्ब ने के लिए
कभी आया किसी के
सामने कभी भी आया है किसी के
सामने चैट में बताइए
क्या सभी ने क्लास को छोड़ दिया
क्या हेलो हेलो आई एम
ऑडिबल ओके नेक्स्ट सबसे पहला जो यूजर
अकाउंट होता है आपके सर्विसेस के केस में
सिस्टम अकाउंट होता है सबसे जो पहले यूजर
अकाउंट होता है कौन सा आपका सिस्टम अकाउंट
होता है द सिस्टम अकाउंट आल्सो नोन एज
एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम कभी भी आपने अगर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन किया होगा तो आप देख
सकते हो वहां पर आपने देखा होगा कई बार
आपको जो एक्सेस मिलता है एंटी अथॉरिटी
सिस्टम दिस इज द हाईएस्ट प्रिविलेज अकाउंट
ओके तो द सिस्टम अकाउंट आल्सो नोन एज एंटी
अथॉरिटी स्टॉक सिस्टम इट ए स्पेशल बिल्ड
इन अकाउंट इन विंडोज दैट इज यूज्ड बाय
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड वेरियस सिस्टम लेवल
सर्विसेस इट इज वन ऑफ द मोस्ट पावरफुल
अकाउंट ऑन ए विंडोज सिस्टम एंड ऑपरेट विद
द हाईएस्ट लेवल ऑफ पिलेज आपका जो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स होता है उससे भी हाई
लेवल के जो प्रिजेस हैं वो किसके पास होते
हैं आपके सिस्टम अकाउंट के पास इट इज
ऑटोमेटिक क्रिएटेडॉक्युमेंट्सफ्रैगमेंट
फॉर्म सिस्टम लेवल टास्क ओके इस तरीके से
आप उसको देख सकते हो लेकिन आपको अभी विज
11 के अंदर नहीं देखने को मिलेगा द सिस्टम
अकाउंट हैज मोर प्रिविलेजेस देन एन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट मेकिंग इट वन ऑफ द
मोस्ट पावरफुल अकाउंट्स इन विंडोज जो इसको
मोस्ट पावरफुल अकाउंट बनाता है विंडोज के
केस में सिस्टम डज नॉट शो अप इन लोकल
यूजर्स एंड ग्रुप्स अभी जो सिस्टम अकाउंट
था आप इसको लोकल यूजर्स और ग्रुप्स के
अंदर देख ही नहीं सकते वहां पर आपको देखने
को नहीं मिलेगा इस तरीके का अकाउंट यू कैन
नॉट ऐड सिस्टम अकाउंट टू एनी यूजर ग्रुप्स
इंक्लूडिंग एडमिनिस्ट्रेट अ इस सिस्टम
यूजर अकाउंट को इवन आप एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ही
भले क्यों ना हो इसको किसी भी यूजर या
ग्रुप का पार्ट नहीं बना सकते ओके ना कोई
इसका आप ग्रुप इसका कोई यूजर्स किसी भी
यूजर्स को पार्ट बना सकते एज एन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर इवन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर भी
इसका पार्ट नहीं हो सकता ओके इट इज नॉट ए
डोमेन अकाउंट इट एजिस्ट ओनली लोकली ऑन
विंडोज मशीन यह विंडोज मशीन पर ही एजिस्ट
करता है स्पेशली
फॉर आपकी सिस्टम प्रोसेस के लिए करता है
ये यह सिस्टम प्रोसेस प ही देखने को
मिलेगा इवन सर्विसेस प भी यह देखने को
नहीं मिलेगा सिस्टम अकाउंट रेयरली है ठीक
है सेकंड जो अकाउंट होता है लोकल सिस्टम
अकाउंट जो आपका सिस्टम अकाउंट है और लोकल
सिस्टम अकाउंट है एक ही है उनकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज उनके ले लेवल ऑफ
प्रिविलेजेस एक ही है लेकिन जो सिस्टम
अकाउंट्स की जो प्रिविलेजेस है और नॉर्मली
आपका जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ करता है
किसके ऊपर जो सिस्टम प्रोसेस स्टार्टअप
प्रोसेस है या सिस्टम प्रोसेस के ऊपर किया
जाता है लेकिन जो सर्विसेस के ऊपर आपको
ज्यादातर देखने को मिलेगा व लोकल सिस्टम
अकाउंट कहने के लिए आपको दो अलग-अलग वर्ड
हैं लोकल सिस्टम अकाउंट और सिस्टम अकाउंट
लेकिन रोल परमिशन सब कुछ सेम है द लोकल
सिस्टम एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम अकाउंट इज
प्री डिफाइंड हाई प्रीज लोकल अकाउंट इस
तरीके आपने देखा था दिस अकाउंट के अंदर
कुछ ऑप्शंस थे दूसरा या लोकल सिस्टम
अकाउंट अभी-अभी आपको दिखाया था तो द लोकल
सिस्टम अकाउंट इज अ प्री डिफाइंड हाई
प्रीज लोकल अकाउंट यूज्ड बाय सर्विस
कंट्रोल मैनेजर सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर को
के द्वारा इस अकाउंट को यूज किया जाता है
एज ए सिस्टम अकाउंट टू रन एसेंशियल विंडोज
सर्विस इट हैज फुल एक्सेस टू द लोकल मशीन
एंड ऑपरेट विदन द विद द हाईएस्ट सिस्टम
लेवल परमिशन और यह सिस्टम हाईएस्ट जो
सिस्टम परमिश होते हैं उसके साथ ऑपरेट
करता है इसके
पास हाईएस्ट लेवल ऑफ परमिशन होती है आपके
किसकी सिस्टम्स की एडमिन के भी पास वो
परमिश नहीं होती दैट इज वई ये प्राइमरी
टारगेट होती है आपके
सर्विसेस इट इज ऑटोमेटिक
क्रिएटेडटेड मिनिस्टेर अकाउंट जो एससीएम
है इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग विंडोज
सर्विसेस इट कैन मॉडिफाई हाउ ए सर्विस
रनिंग अंडर द लोकल सिस्टम अकाउंट बेसिकली
मेरे कहने का मतलब क्या है
कि जो सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर चाहे तो इस
अकाउंट की हेल्प से आपकी जो सर्विसेस को
मॉडिफाई कर सकता है आपके एक्सेस को
रिस्ट्रिक्टर है सर्विस के एक्सेस को
रिस्ट्रिक्टर सकता है कौन आपका एससीएम बाय
डिफॉल्ट लोकल सिस्टम हैज फुल नेटवर्क
एक्सेस होता है मीनिंग इट कैन एक्सेस
नेटवर्क शेयर्स ऑथेंटिकेट टू रिमोट सिस्टम
एज एन कंप्यूटर इट सेल्फ हाउ एवर विंडोज
कैन रिस्ट्रिक्टर सिस्टम नेटवर्क एक्स टू
प्रिवेंट सिक्योरिटी रि लेकिन आपका जो
सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर चाहे तो इस लोकल
सिस्टम अकाउंट पर भी रिस्ट्रिक्शन यू कर
सकता है इस अकाउंट को यूज करके किसी
पर्टिकुलर सर्विसेस के को नेटवर्क एक्सेस
रिस्ट्रिक्टर सकता है कि ओके यह इतना ही
एक्सेस कर सकती है इतने ही शेयर एक्सेस कर
सकती है किसी को रिमोट एक्सेस नहीं कर
सकती ताकि आपके सिस्टम को सिक्योरिटी
रिस्क कम हो तो कहने का मतलब क्या है
सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर इज द ओनली
जो क्या कर सकता है आपके सिस्टम्स के ऊपर
सर्विसेस के साथ मॉडिफिकेशन कर सकता है एज
पर देयर सिक्योरिटी से सेटिंग और देयर
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज अदर वाइज हूमन
इंटरेक्शन है ही नहीं हमन कुछ भी नहीं कर
सकते विंडोज के केस में ओके नाउ अभी बात
करते हैं हम नेटवर्क सर्विस अकाउंट की दिस
इज अनदर स्पेशल अकाउंट दैट वी कैन यूज टू
रन सर्विसेस जिसका हम यूज कर सकते हैं
सर्विसेस को रन करने के लिए दैट इज कॉल्ड
नेट नेटवर्क सर्विस ओके थर्ड अकाउंट है ये
दिस अकाउंट इज प्री डिफाइंड बाय द लोकल
अकाउंट एंड इज यूज्ड बाय द एससीएम इसको जो
लोकल अकाउंट है उसके द्वारा डिफाइन किया
गया है बट यह सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर के
द्वारा यूज किया जाता है नेटवक नेटवर्क
सर्विस अकाउंट इज ए स्पेशल बिल्ट इन
विंडोज अकाउंट यूज टू रन सर्विसेस विद लो
प्रिविलेजेस इसके पास हाईयर प्रिविलेजेस
नहीं होते इसके पास लो प्रिविलेजेस होते
हैं स्टिल बीइंग टू एक्सेस नेटवर्क लेकिन
फिर भी उन प्रिजेस के साथ यह क्या कर सकता
है नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस को एक्सेस कर सकता
है और इट इज प्री डिफाइंड बाय विंडोज एंड
मैनेज बाय सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर इसको भी
सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर के द्वारा क्या
किया जाता है कंट्रोल किया जाता है इस
तरीके से दिस अकाउंट यहां पर आप सेलेक्ट
कर सकते हो इट हैज लो लोकल प्रिविलेजेस बट
कैन ऑथेंटिकेट ऑन द नेटवर्क यूजिंग द मशीन
कशन लेकिन अगर चाहे तो यह हायर प्रिजेस के
लिए शिफ्ट कर सकता है अपने आप को नेटवर्क
एक्सेस नेटवर्क का एक्सेस ले सकता है शेयर
को एक्सेस कर सकता है या रिमोट एक्सेस कर
सकता है विद दी हेल्प ऑफ जो आपकी मशीन है
उसके क्रेडेंशियल को यूज करके लेकिन आप
एचसीएम की हेल्प से इनको भी क्या कर सकते
हो रिस्ट्रिक्टर सकते हो ओके विद दी हेल्प
ऑफ एचसीएम इस नेटवर्क सर्विस अकाउंट के
अंदर भी आप क्या कर सकते हो रिस्ट्रिक्शंस
लगा सकते हो बट यह चाहे तो नेटवर्क एक्सेस
भी कर सकता है इसके पास भले ही लो लोकल
प्रिविलेज लॉ है बट यह फिर भी ऑथेंटिकेशन
की हेल्प से नेटवर्क एक्सेस कर सकता है
ओके इतना पावरफुल यह भी है नाउ फोर्थ लोकल
सर्विस अकाउंट दैट इज द लास्ट काउंट द
लोकल सर्विस अकाउंट इज ए बिल्ट इन एंड
प्री डिफाइंड लोकल अकाउंट इन
विंडोज यूज्ड बाय सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर
यह भी सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर के द्वारा
यूज किया जाता है सर्विसेस को रन करने के
लिए विद मिनिमल प्रिविलेजेस सबसे जो कम
प्रिविलेज होते हैं वो इस लोकल सर्विस
अकाउंट के पास होते हैं इट इज डिजाइन फॉर
सर्विस दैट नीड लिमिटेड एक्सेस टू लोकल
सिस्टम रिसोर्सेस वाइल प्रेजेंटिंग
एनोनिमस क्रेडेंशियल ऑन द नेटवर्क अगर
नेटवर्क को एक्सेस करना है तो इसको
क्रेडेंशियल की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होती
ओके एनोनिमस एक्सेस मिनिमम प्रिविलेज ऑफ द
लोकल कट बेसिक सबसे मिनिमम प्रिविलेज इसके
पास होते हैं द लोकल सर्विस अकाउंट हैज
फ्यूअर प्रिजेस देन लोकल सिस्टम और
नेटवर्क सर्विस नेटवर्क सर्विस जो अकाउंट
है या जो लोकल सिस्टम अकाउंट जो सिस्टम
अकाउंट की बात उससे तो बहुत ही ज्यादा कम
प्रिज इसके पास होते हैं इट कैन नॉट
मॉडिफाई सिस्टम सेटिंग यह अकाउंट सिस्टम
की सेटिंग को मॉडिफाई नहीं कर सकता
सेंसिटिव फाइल को एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता
ओनली रीड और एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है उसके
ऊपर यही परमिशन रहती है रीड और एग्जीक्यूट
की ही परमिशन रहती है किसी भी सर्विस से
रिलेटेड एससीएम मैनेज विंडोज सर्विसेस एंड
असाइन अकाउंट लाइक लोकल सर्विस फॉर रनिंग
देम अब
एससीएम इसको भी विंडोज सर्विसेस के ऊपर
मैनेज कर मतलब सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर कुछ
भी कर सकता है एनोनिमस क्रेडेंशियल ऑन द
नेटवर्क का मतलब क्या है व्हेन एक्सेसिंग
नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस लोकल सर्विस डज नॉट यूज
मशीन क्रेडेंशियल
शल्स को यूज नहीं करता नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेस
को क्या करने के लिए एक्सेस करने के लिए
इट इट प्रेजेंट एनोनिमस क्रेडेंशियल
मीनिंग इट हैज नो ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑन रिमोट
सिस्टम अनलेस एक्सप्लिसिट कन्फर आप उसको
चाहो तो एक्सप्लीसिटली मतलब खुद से कंफिल
कर सकते हो जरूरी नहीं है कि ये एनोनिमस
ही रहे क्रेडेंशियल को कंफिल भी किया जा
सकता है ओके तो दीज आर द फोर अकाउंट्स दैट
आर वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टू नो जब आप क्या
करोगे जब विंडोज प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन आप
परफॉर्म करोगे तो वहां पर आप जब सर्विसेस
को क्या करोगे
[संगीत]
अब्यूड़ोस
अकाउंट है फिर भी प्रज मेरे पास मीडियम है
दैट इज व्हाई आई एम टेलिंग यू कि सर्विसेस
अकाउंट के साथ यह अकाउंट लिंक होते हैं और
इनके पास यह ये प्रिज होती है वैसे आपको
सेट करने की या कन्फर करने की कहीं पर भी
जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि साइबर सिक्योरिटी
के अंदर यह आपका काम नहीं है आपका काम है
पेन टेस्ट करना लेकिन आपके पास अगर ये
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं होगी तो आप ब्लाइंड पेन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे होंगे और हो सकता है कि
इस तरह की इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने आए लेकिन
विदाउट नॉलेज आप उसको मिस कर जाओ ओके
इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट यह है विंडोज सर्विस
अकाउंट आर वन ऑफ द मोस्ट प्रेफर्ड अटैक
सरफेस फॉर प्रिविलेज एक्सलेन
इफ यू आर एबल टू कंप्रोमाइज सच एन अकाउंट
जिन अकाउंट की मैंने बात की इट इज क्वाइट
इजी टू गेट द हाईएस्ट प्रिविलेजेस मेनली
ड्यू टू पावरफुल इंपर्सनेशन प्रिविलेजेस
दैट आर ग्रांटेड बाय डिफॉल्ट टू सर्विसेस
बाय द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फिर भी किसी भी एक
नॉर्मल यूजर या किसी भी एक एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
से तो ज्यादा ही प्रिविलेज है इन चारों
अकाउंट के पास ठीक है दैट इज वई दि द
मोस्ट
प्रेफर्ड अटैक सरफेस फर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन बाय एनी पेंटेस्टर
एथिकल हैकर्स या अटैकर तो यहां तक यह था
ला आज का टॉपिक हमारा विंडोज सर्विसेस तो
शायद सबको समझ में आ गया विंडो सर्विस
होते क्या है उनको कौन कंट्रोल करता है
और कौन उनको मैनेज करता है ओके और विंडो
सर्विसेस के लिए कौन-कौन से अकाउंट
रिस्पांसिबल होते हैं रन करने के लिए
एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल नाउ
यस रियल वर्ल्ड विंडो 10 पर भी अटैक
परफॉर्म होते हैं आफ्टर इनिला अब इनिशियल
एक्सेस लेने के बाद तो हो जाएंगे पॉसिबल
है तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है तो किसी का
कोई सवाल जवाब आप मुझसे पूछ सकते
हैं आज के सेशन से रिलेटेड एवरीवन क्लियर
प्लीज बताइए
क्या बात चोरी करने की सलाह है क्या
विनोद विदाउट परमिशन मत करना मैं आपको बोल
रहा हूं विदाउट परमिशन डू नॉट परफॉर्म एनी
मिशिस एक्टिविटी अदर
वाइज आईटी लॉज इतने स्ट्रिक्ट है लाइफ
बर्बाद हो जाएगी अगर कंप्लेन हो गई तो
अब मैं आपको रिकमेंड नहीं करूंगा मैं आपको
नहीं बोलूंगा कि आपको उस पर करना चाहिए
टेक परमिशन टेक रिक्वेस्ट रिटर्न परमिशन
देन ओनली परफॉर्म योर अटैक और देन प्रूव
कीजिए मत कीजिए हां बिल्कुल वरना करियर
स्टार्ट होने से पहले ही आपका खत्म हो
जाएगा किसी का कोई सवाल है कोई जवाब है
मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं उसके अदर वाइज हम सेशन
को एंड कर
देंगे मेरे ख्याल से लोग मुझसे पूछ कि सर
कितने और टॉपिक आएंगे मतलब आप बोर हो गए
आपका कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
इसमें तो मत आइए क्लास
में मैं बंद कर दूंगा मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा
ठीक है
विनोद अगर आपको इंटरेस्ट नहीं बन रहा
टॉपिक्स में अगर आप से कंसर्न इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है तो डोंट कम इन द क्लास मैं किसी
से रिक्वेस्ट नहीं कर रहा जिन दिन क्लास
में पाच या
10 पाच से और 10 के बीच में स्टूडेंट बच
जाएंगे ओनली सिक्स और सेन आएंगे उस दिन
मैं इस कोर्स को बंद कर दूंगा उसके बाद एक
अनाउंसमेंट आएगी रीजन के साथ व कोर्स को
बंद कर दिया जाएगा फिर उसके बाद इस कोर्स
को रिओपन नहीं किया जाएगा इस कोर्स को फिर
से नया कोर्स बनाया जाएगा लेकिन पेड कोर्स
बनाया जाएगा जिसको करना है तो कीजिए नहीं
करना तो मत कीजिए
विनोद आपका स्वाल सर इस नेक्स्ट वीडियो
टॉपिक तो बता दूंगा लेकिन आपने क्या बोला
और कितने टॉपिक इस पर आने वाले
हैं आपको तो ऐसा होना चाहिए सर टॉपिक्स
कितने भी देते रहो कितने भी देते रहो नो
प्रॉब्लम तो एक काम करते सेशन को एंड करते
हैं
फिर ओके तो बाय बाय एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
किसी को कोई डाउट है फिर भी आपको लगता है
कि मेरा डाउट है तो आप मुझसे काम कर सकते
हैं कमेंट सेशन में इस वीडियो के कमेंट
सेशन में टैग कीजिए और अपना डाउट पूछिए
नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपके डाउट को क्लियर कर
दिया जाएगा तब तक के लिए सेशन को एंड करते
हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन आपका रजिस्ट्री होगा
आपको पहले बता दिया रजिस्ट्री के ऊपर आपका
सेशन होगा विंडोज की जो रजिस्ट्री होती है
होती क्या है और कैसी दिखती है और किस
परपज से है इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको दी जाएगी
बस इतना ही सेशन होगा नेक्स्ट विंडोज
रजिस्ट्री देन उसके बाद एक दो टॉपिक और बच
गए आपके बेसिक फंडामेंटल्स के देन फिर हम
धीरे-धीरे विंडोज पेन टेस्टिंग प स्टार्ट
कर देंगे ओके तो बाय बाय टेक
केयर नहीं पावर सेल नहीं आएगा पावर सेल नॉ
दि नॉट द पार्ट ऑफ दिस कोर्स एडवांस कोर्स
का पार्ट है तो पावर सेल नहीं करवाऊंगी
मैं तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं बाय बाय टेक
केयर एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन बाय एंड
गुड नाइट